Welcome back everyone it's Charlie, the boys
is here, diabolical.
This is going to be my season 2 episode 1,
2 and 3 video they dropped the first 3 episodes.
I will be doing weekly episode videos for
all them.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
We're doing an Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the episodes on
the video.
Normally I would do top 10 and Easter eggs,
but there's so much stuff happening in these
episodes and it's all 3 episodes in this one
video that it should be like top 100.
And it's the boys series.
So it's way crazier than most television shows,
because they drop the first three episodes
just careful for spoilers for episodes 1 to
3.
So what i'll do is i'll number these as we
go along through the episodes and cover all
the Easter eggs, but if you don't follow them
on social media, they actually dropped the
episodes a day early Thursday instead of Friday
when they were supposed to drop as part of
this big promotional campaign.
It was meant to be a joke about Vought taking
over the boys twitter account in the boys
and butcher leaking the episodes in retaliation
a day early.
The titles of the episodes are also titles
of the comic book chapters, but the actual
chapters don't necessarily correspond the
plot of the episodes, but it starts with the
CEO of Vought played by Giancarlo Esposito's
much bigger character during Season 2.
His name is Stan Edgar so Homelander's like
the evil Superman of this equation he would
be more like the Lex Luther he's negotiating
with Jim beaver from supernatural who works
for the government about the terms of putting
superheroes in the military that whole thing
they're trying to set during season one wall
black noir is busy on his mission to take
out the new foreign villain Homelander help
create the very purpose of convincing the
government in the military to let superheroes
in all while sympathy for the devil by the
stones is playing.
I guess that kind of makes Giancarlo Esposito's
character that quote of quote devil of the
situation.
Even though you can think of black noir is
a devil of sorts and a lot of people are wondering
how different or how similar he's going to
be the comic book version of his character.
Please don't post spoilers about black noir
in the comments, because while this hit mission
is going on the takes down this for a superhero.
He soaks a bunch of damage revealing that
he has a whole bunch of powers that you didn't
know about.
But the sympathy for the devil song also applies
to him because this scene where he brings
the severed head and this bunny in to freak
that little kid out of the next room.
That's also a reference to comic book black
noir being the worst worst possible person.
You can imagine.
If you think characters on the TV show or
bad black noir in the comics is so so much
worse so much more.
If you didn't see my video about it.
There's a bunch of supernatural characters
and people that worked on the supernatural
TV show that are associated with the boys
TV show now.
So I reference Jim beaver who played Bobby
on supernatural Jensen Ackles is actually
good to be playing soldier boy or a version
of soldier boy during season three.
I don't know how many episodes is going to
be in, but I worry that a video about that.
So a link at the end of this but Eric Kripkey
who's the showrunner of the boys actually
used to be the showrunner of supernatural
so maybe we get Jared Padalecki in the future
Season 2 just complete the circle.
One of the big Easter eggs they have during
this conversation, though, when Giancarlo
Esposito's talking to Jim beaver is makes
a reference to telling the president what
to do, the United States president and that's
a big arc in the comic books Vauxhall mission
is that they want more power.
But in order to get real power they have to
be able to get superheroes in the government.
So superheroes in the military is a big thing
right now on the show, but the next big step
as they tease here is putting superheroes
in the White House and I love the joke about
collateral damage.
34% of any city that they go to was superheroes
the wind up trashing so they almost cause
as much damage as they prevent the canap\'e9
that off by the time we get to episode three
with Kimiko's brother in Stormfront going
after both of them which he completely trashes
in entire building just because she feels
like it but then they transition to the funeral
for translucent with Homelander giving this
really terrible speech trying to continue
to spin this is a big PR move everything that
Vought does is basically a PR move.
Up until this point, pretty much everything
that they say everything that they do is all
meant to just continue to feed their big merchandising
machine cell more Murch he see couple jokes
about that to when Hughie goes out on the
street walking around you see merch for the
seven all over the place in then when they
go to the warehouse with all the superhero
costumes it's all Vought Merch.
They also have wall-to-wall commercials and
TV shows all trying to pump up this narrative
that they're trying to feed to the public
about what Vought wants them to believe they
try to pin everything on butcher in spin him
is this crazy person they're not wrong about
that.
Butcher is definitely crazy as a sort of implied
later in the episodes you can kind of see
that Vought is trying to control everything
we meet up with the deep who still stuck in
Ohio and exile from the seven drinking his
problems away getting kicked out of some TGI
Friday's looking bar his arc is kind of hilarious
in a very sad way, like the sorely spirals
out of control in that waterpark.
The funny thing about his arc with the Colts
because he totally falls for he totally eats
up everything that they feed him is it is
meant to be a parallel for Hughie's arc because
he's also spiraling out of control and he
keeps watching that Billy Joel music video,
they actually included the beginning of episode
three.
I think for the deep it winds up being the
Colts that he runs to but like Hughie says
we get to episode three.
He talks about starlight being his quote of
quote second wind, like the Billy Joel song
for set up.
The whole compound V are trying to expose
Vought.
I know a lot of people heard that compound
V in their wondering if the going to do that
big q. week comic book twists because he keeps
talking about being this normal guy.
I'm just a normal guy that nobody thinks his
special, but it makes all these pop-culture
references like I could be the Harry Potter
of this group.
I don't want to talk too much about that in
case winds up being spoilers later this season
is a big twist with Hughie's character in
the comics that you can go read if you want
to right now, but they might wind up doing
that for his character by the end of this
season.
The mission that the boys sent her on though
is part of this to get her former squad made
to turn and help her with a compound V is
actually right out of the comics to she used
to be part of the super religious thing group
called the young Americans drummer boy in
the comics is the person she used to go out
with this person is called gecko.
So just a minor change in the comics, but
that was all in service of this big twist
they could have this scene of him getting
paid to let people hack limbs off even says
to let them chop is junk off if he gives an
extra thousand bucks.
I also love this hilarious look on starlight's
face like this is gross, but it's not the
worst thing she seen in the last year they
said.
The whole cult arc with the deep's character
getting bailed out of jail by Eagle who's
obviously a big parity of Hawkeye in the Avengers.
There are a lot of Marvel Avengers Easter
eggs throughout the series and during Season
2 the seven are just a Justice league parody,
and Homelander sent to be evil Superman, but
there a lot of other Marvel base character
parities in the show that he's part of the
church of the collective either willingly
or unwillingly maybe he's been brainwashed
to it's hard to tell how much he believes
what's going on, but they said that the big
fresco running joke.
So anytime a cult member walks in and introduces
themselves.
They keep trying to give you Fresca so fair
warning if anybody in real life offers you
a fresco you turn and you run the opposite
way.
I don't know which writer it was on the show
who declared war on Fresca, but it's actually
hilarious when they go back to the boys that
make a reference on the TV about Stillwell's
baby surviving and being found 17 miles away.
So as Homelander really did say that they
be just dropped it off while he was taking
butcher to his wife's house.
It is so weird and gross, watching him drink
that to milk the way he does.
He's so obsessed with it.
He drinks milk so weird on the show so many
different times that you just have to laugh
out loud have a big joke about Ashley kind
of catching him doing it to I think she definitely
saw him drinking that to milk they have another
big Marvel Easter egg with this daredevil
parity character Homelander just completely
turns on a dime to just slapping his ears.
I love how Anthony stars so good at that too,
like he seems like he's kind of going along
with things congratulating him, giving him
the usual spiel he would do in front of cameras
and completely gives her the business about
being the one in charge.
You can inform me on everything that's going
on inside corporate and I'm going to do whatever
I want to do that is really last very long
to you can see by the end of episode three
Homelander is just ready to just completely
blow apart at the seams because he feels like
he's completely lost control the situation.
This is a lot of references during episode
one to this Tek Knight movie this getting
ready to come out.
He's basically a version of Batman and Iron
Man.
If you're not a big comic book reader.
He's a superhero that is a ton of money but
no real superpowers other than the technology
that he uses to fight crime.
He also has a big Batcave to we need more
members of the church of the collective as
the deep slowly kind of get sucked in through
all the Fresca they make him trip balls and
he starts talking to his gills which are voiced
by Patton Oswalt when they announced that
he was going to be a character on the show.
I thought he was edgy to be a real character,
but this is way crazier than I ever expected.
Then they introduce Stormfront for the first
time played by Aya cash most of you might
recognize her from some other TV show.
She does a lot of comedy stuff.
She's meant to be a character.
This just as bad if not worse than Homelander,
but in the first three episodes she's a bit
of a slow burn like the slowly easing you
into how crazy she really is until the end
of episode three.
The whole thing with her is that she's actually
almost as powerful as Homelander to she's
meant to be this check and balance that Oscar
puts on the team as a strategic move to sort
of neutralize Homelander, but even though
Homelander seems like he hates her at the
beginning of the season and for most of the
episodes like the end of episode three.
It seems like he's getting ready to stare
a hole right through her like he wants to
laser the crap out of her Aya cash said that
she slowly wins him over, over the course
of the season when she reveals what's really
going on and if you see the trailer like the
scene of him lays during her chest and her
enjoying it than them getting it on.
Obviously that was not in the first three
episodes, so it sounds as though how the confrontation
pretty soon, but everyone present Evan the
chat for that deputy director the CIA from
season one the one that had been together
with butcher for a while helping them out
to fully explain why her head blew up only
that Vought has tabs on pretty much everybody
in a position of power just trying to keep
the lid on compound be in the reason why she
died is because she got too close to the secret,
but the secret gets out by episode three.
Anyway that they.
The big standoff with Homelander in the CEO
sort of telling him what the business is and
giving us a big history lesson about the company
Vought to change a couple minor things about
the comics, but for the most part it's a pretty
accurate Backstory.
It all started in World War II Germany then
through operation paperclip the company in
then compound V came to the United States
where they founded Vought American butcher
comes back.
Finally daddy's home and explains to the rest
the boys that his wife is still alive and
what is real plan is.
This can be a short movie that will cover
the events between season one in season to
about what butcher was up to during that missing.
I think that's going to drop after the finale
of Season 2 drops.
They finally reveal where she is when she
drops her son offer piano lessons and races
back and we find out that Vought is been keeping
her in this giant Jurassic Park looking facility
with a huge fence around it and I love the
conversation that she has with the doctor
about what they're going to do about Homelander.
Now that he knows the secret.
I don't if there's anything we can do about
it were just kind of hoping he'll get tired
and move on later.
They remind you just how powerful Homelander
is when he tells her about that conversation
letting you know that he heard every word.
Even though he was a couple miles away Homelander
also kind of gets real with his son for a
moment to look.
He tells the truth.
You know I kind of like you earlier.
I didn't really have a mom or a dad I didn't
grow up with that many friends like a couple
brief moments during the episodes where you
see him with his son actually enjoying himself
because he so badly wants a family, but he
doesn't know how to do that he does not to
be human in Anthony Starr, the actor actually
says that Homelander's real kryptonite quote
of quote for making Superman references is
actually his humanity because he wants to
be a father to his son.
The father that he never had, but through
his actions he almost winds of burning that
bridge because his sons powers finally activate
when he threatens butcher's wife get away
from us.
I hate you I don't want to be anything like
you that's big because their only a couple
people on the planet that are almost powerful
enough to challenge Homelander and his son
would be one of those people Stormfront is
almost as powerful as Homelander, but she's
a little bit better at spitting PR which is
why she seems like she's more in control some
of the situations which also pieces Homelander
off even more.
The set of the whole arc with Kimiko's brother.
He basically got the same compound V treatments
from the same group the chemical did is that
she was rescued by the boys and he was not
so he's still working for them to have a series
of conversations about what happened to them
after they left their village they basically
explain that Homelander destroyed everyone
there so there's no way that they could ever
go back even if they wanted to, but also he
feels all this remorse for not being able
to protect her because he supposed to be her
brother.
He tells the story about how he took the blame
for her when she was about to get caught for
stealing they broke his hands, which they
pay off at the end of episode three, when
he comes back to rescue her from Stormfront,
but she breaks his hands and then kills them.
This is whole butcher versus Hughie thing
going on in the first couple of episodes to
wear Hughley just as one of anything to do
with butcher and butcher basically tells them
if you get in my way between me and my wife.
This plan all kill you and he is not joking.
The show is not subtle about it at all, but
they wanted parallel butcher in Homelander
they're both meant to be psychopaths for the
most part of their own way is just a question
of whether or not either will find any kind
of redemption by the end of episode three
starlight's plan to leak the news about compound
V is out, the world knows about it.
But Giancarlo Esposito's character winds up
pinning the whole thing on Stillwell because
she can't say anything about it because she's
dead now.
He also kind of pins Volga bomb on it like
a small rogue group insider company the speech
the kid to Homelander earlier in the season
is actually really good explains their business
really well.
We are a pharmaceutical company in our power
is really that no one knows the secret of
superheroes that we make them.
There are no superheroes that are born naturally
Homelander's son is one of the first big experiments
in that because he was born naturally.
He does have powers.
So now they know that it's at least possible
for superheroes to be born one of the funnier
things though about that compound V reveal
is that some of the members of the seven only
learned about it for the first time from the
news they didn't know that they were created
superheroes.
They thought that they been born that way.
It was the deep the talked about learning
about his powers for the first time when he
was a young child walking to the mall listening
to all the goldfish screaming then you see
black noir crying in the hallway early's looks
like he's crying underneath his mask their
couple really funny black noir background
scenes to.
So he's all over the spectrum there a couple
of the big cameos like PJ byrne, you probably
recognize him from a couple of the TV shows.
This is really just the beginning and obvious
he there's a lot of stuff that I didn't include
in this video just because there's so much
that we could talk about from each episode.
So by episode four video will post next Friday,
but if he spotted any big Easter eggs that
I didn't include in the video just write them
below in the comments like is that there's
a billion things that they reference during
these will do is all talk more about some
of the new characters we get to the more the
single episode videos like Stormfront.
There's a bunch of stuff going on with Stormfront
that we could talk about where you wait for
everything.
Click here for brand-new Star Wars the Mandalorian
Season 2 teaser trailer and click here for
that boys Jensen Ackles teaser video think
you so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!